hey I'm the star of Halle I'm Lorraine
and I am NOT a scroll I am Langston and
this is Earth's Mightiest show we are
counting down the seconds to Marvel
Studios Captain Marvel and to help us
out we have the women of Marvel hosts
here sana Amanat and Judy Stevens so
much for joining us on this jam-packed
show we're gonna be talking to the
directors the cast of the film the fans
oh and so much more it's gonna be great
Senate Judy you guys are such an
important part I think of Captain Marvel
because you guys are not only fans but
have influenced her sana you've edited
lots of Captain Marvel comics Judy you
are an important member of the Carol
core why do you think Captain Marvel is
such an important character well you
know I think she's so amazing because
she has so many different types of
skills like she can do everything she's
a fighter pilot and then she happens to
at these powers and becomes a powerful
superhero but I feel like that's just
like added bonus like she's done so much
in the past to come to where she is and
at the same time she's a little
vulnerable and she loves the people
around her and I just feel like she's
like a full she's like a full human
being there's so much to her she's a
hero before she's ever given super
totally exactly yeah and I also love
that she's fearless and unapologetic you
know she's just doing what she needs to
do and she's that icon for young girls
and boys everywhere mm-hmm and the film
hits theaters on International Women's
Day which is such a cool way to
celebrate women all over the world right
I know I'm pumped so why do you think
Captain Marvel resonates with so many
people you know what I love about Carol
is her motto higher further faster she's
constantly trying to be the best become
better to push past all of these
limitations that people might have put
upon her and I think that is so
relatable that's really everything that
we all want in ourselves and I think
that's such a strong message not only
obviously to send all of our fans but
particularly the young fans a young
girl's a young women seeing all of the
different costumes that people are
putting on and dressing up as Captain
Marvel already it's just so inspiring
and so amazing to say I want to be
friends with Carol can she hang out with
me I did words could we be Fred
I stand for it all so let's get down to
some MIDI gritty what are we looking
forward to the most in the film well
first of all I have to say her helmet
and the way that it comes I don't
totally crazy but when the most
controversial thing that happened when
the comic came out was the fact that
like her hair looked totally I mean I
thought it looked amazing but it was
controversial because we cut it a little
bit and people were upset about it but
what as soon as you put on that vent
helmet and she has that like mohawk yeah
I think she looks incredible and there's
moments in the film where you see her
kind of flying with that look in space
and it's just oh my god it just gives me
so many gels I mean the costume is
amazing really yeah like just being able
to like see it on screen at all to come
together from like coming from the
comics to now I mean I'm so excited
yeah I really I love this choice to put
her in the 90s I mean one love the 90s I
have a baby for ya and I think it's just
like such a cool setting for it because
we get younger fury we get younger
Coulson up in the mix so we get to see
you there sort of origins and then we
also get all this 90 realness where yes
like at the blockbuster I feel like that
was the last time I had any sent any
fashion sense - am i cool I'm cool again
that's awesome give me a tattoo choker
okay I'm very excited to see brie Larson
the the way that she inhabits this
character from what you see in the
trailers I got chills when you see all
the different variations the fighter
pilot her in space and all these
iterations that she goes through I can't
wait I'm I'm excited I'm excited see it
I mean and we have the kree's in the
scrolls and we have someone I know
Judy's excited for a my good goose the
cat I knew that would make Judy excited
as a cat mom also I heard that you
caught up with the fans to talk about
Captain Marvel yeah actually I headed
down to midtown comics to hear what
people had to say about why Kara was one
of their favorite heroes
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's your name where you're from I'm
Daniel Eric hey I'm Michelle hi my name
is Kristen I'm Jude and I'm from England
I feel like our names are very similar I
appreciate this and what does Captain
Marvel mean to you progress really I
need some nice character because she had
wanted dignity and she goes around
fighting pseudonyms
it's just just an overall strength and
and a great role model the fact that she
feels like a real human being she feels
like she could be you or me and that's
that makes the best hero I think to me
she means like femininity you can be
beautiful and you can also have a mohawk
and I think that's the world we live in
and that's the world I want to live in
you could be strong women we can be
women that are fearless and unapologetic
and all of that combined she's a very
strong and independent character and it
means a lot for tonight for like self
confidence in people and like people
like myself and other women who don't
feel like they're represented enough
it's very strong it's more for my
daughters
you know girls need that extra of Asiya
a powerful person and with superheroes
that's perfect also she owns a cat and
I'm completely biased for her cats so
she automatically gets an a-plus in my
book I'm on the cat train full stop cat
all the way oh yeah oh my god it was so
much fun
talking to all the amazing fans and just
sharing the love my favorite part is
meeting fans for the first time
particularly Carole core members because
they're just so passionate and so
excited and just like seeing them in
their uniforms and showcasing to Captain
Marvel love I feel like that's what's
gonna happen in the next couple of
months so I'm very very excited I cannot
wait oh you know what I actually got to
swing by the set of Marvel Studios
Captain Marvel speaking of some hardcore
Carroll core fans the directors and
abuddin and Ryan Fleck were there and I
got to hear about the making of the film
enjoy this is a superhero story about
somebody who the more they kind of get
in touch with their humanity
and the more that they accept their own
humanity the more powerful she becomes
the creature Omar is a big part of the
background
this movie it's something that Captain
Marvel has caught up in and ends up on
earth and earth gets in the middle of it
the scrolls are really really fun part
of the comic book history to bring to
life in the cinematic universe I've
never been Scrolls before and what could
be more fun than telling a story about
aliens and characters who could look
literally like anybody we meet Nick Fury
and Phil Coulson and a blockbuster in
this movie which is kind of exciting but
where are they at I mean Nick Fury
doesn't know that superheroes exist he
doesn't know that aliens exist he learns
a lot in this movie he's kind of he's a
guy who's thinks he's seen it all coming
into this movie and then realizes some
way he's not seeing it all on his mind
is about to get blown breathing heavily
yes she's the best she's a superhero on
camera and off it is insane how dynamic
the character that she plays in this
movie is and how much she brings to it
she got so invested in just the physical
aspect of this movie and she learned to
fight she trained for months and and the
she does so many of her own stunts in
this movie it's completely insane
because it's not something she's ever
done before so there's that aspect of it
and then there's the emotional aspect of
it which is obviously she can bring so
much humanity to it and ultimately this
is a superhero story about somebody who
the the more they kind of get in touch
with their own humanity and the more
that they accept their own humanity the
more powerful she becomes and so she was
just absolutely the right person for
this it was honestly just it was so cool
being on that set because you can't see
it completely but we were on the cringe
at like an actual point yet it's all
like a big huge built set piece it's
essentially a whole plane that lights up
with all the gears and whistles inside
so cool I actually really appreciate if
they talked so much about how Bri worked
so hard on training for that film
because I actually got the opportunity
to
octa brie and about her experience on
the set and what it was like being
captain marvel but she told me about how
hard she worked to make sure she could
get to a point where she pushed a Jeep
up a hill which I thought was amazing so
I'm like oh my god you really are
Captain Moore yeah it like in real life
in real life yeah like beating up like
people like I believe now in jumping on
trains I'm like oh yeah you can do that
I'd go do that unless you're an actual
superhero but I will say if you get
stuck on the side of the road after brie
Larson for help you can push your car
all the way to the next rest stop yes
Judy you've been very very busy because
you got a chance to chat with the cast
of Marvel Studios Captain Marvel yes I
did I did but I'm not gonna spoil it
just watch it instead you kept my shoes
on oh yeah you like my look I have some
of those like I'm warning it I'm meant
to wear them today and I do I'm here
with real Arsene Samuel Jackson he's
with Chyna Lynch an abode and rain
flight for Marvel Studios Captain Marvel
the directors I'm super excited to talk
to you
you guys are epic as the Star Force what
was it about both of your characters
that really was the thing you wanted to
dig into I think I think mine would be
that the absolute belief that his way is
the right way right yeah a similar thing
I think you know Minerva very much
subscribes to the Kree ideology you know
for better or worse rightly or wrongly
you know I love to kind of you know tap
into that side of things and the
physicality of it because what was it
about Maria that like made you most
excited to dig into it she's a fighter
pilot in a single mother two superheroes
of their own I think and I think when
people see like the new cast of Marvel
movies they go like who's a superhero
who's a superhero who's it and like not
everyone has powers in the literal sense
that some people have powers inside
she's already like setting up a new
generation of young women that I like
gonna come up and take over the worlds
you know I mean she's just casually
doing it just by being her so I've seen
the film and I like went into the film
like I took like a before and after
photo because you did very well known as
like a huge Captain Marvel fan it was
everything I wanted
what is it for you to work with like
leshawna and all these different women
the Shan is really good in this movie
and the fact that like if you want to
boil it down to like your typical plot
points in a movie that we can pinpoint
and say that the love story is a love
story between two best friends is really
important and special to me and to
recognize that that type of friendship
can be just as powerful and as fierce as
any romantic one is like a revolution in
itself because that to me is like a huge
part of what this movie is so great on
film together like it's so fun it's
really enjoyable like I could stop
laughing all the time you guys are like
what up being like have a film that you
know has a serious subject in the center
of it you know somebody trying to
retrace their identity or find out who
they are or discover who they are what
their potential is and to be able to put
some you know humor in that and you know
the the heart of her relationship with
Miz Rambo her flying partner and her
daughter is really touching so there are
a lot of lot of notes get hit in this
film that don't normally get hit and
what people refer to as superhero movies
what is it like to bring Carroll and
Captain Marvel and all this stuff to the
fans at home it's awesome I mean it's
really exciting the fact that there's
such a huge built-in enthusiastic fan
base for this movie is unlike anything
we've ever done before and it's just
we're excited to to bring it to the
world and and part of that for me is
just that she's so human and it's like
her embracing that humanity that
compassion valuing herself for who she
really is and that's what gives her her
most power I mean that that is something
that I'm just excited to bring two
little boys and little girls everywhere
if there was one word for Captain Marvel
what would it be for you dynamic truth
individuality one word alright it's
about her heart I think yeah
oh my goodness that seeing the cast
they're such a tight-knit family and
seeing how excited they are about
Captain Marvel I'm very excited to this
movie even more now yes and there's so
much amazing star power oh my god like I
just couldn't like my eyes were darting
from like one person I'm like I'm so
excited I'm so excited but alright good
so great and Judy you guys are gonna be
doing a whole Captain Marvel sort of
themed celebration on women of Marvel
right yeah we have three special
episodes you guys should go check it out
yeah I love it oh you know what links
and I know that you also have been
gearing up for more ways to get into the
Marvel Universe so I want to know what
can we expect from Marvel game ah yes
games games games I love them alright so
I got you so chickens that a whole bunch
of mobile games are ready to go higher
further faster with special content
inspired by Marvel Studios Captain
Marvel new events featuring the Kree and
Skrulls are already playable on both the
marvel strike force and marvel future
fight they do not get along well no and
new cards are available you're gonna
love this judi new cards are gonna be
available for Captain Marvel Nick Fury
and goose the cat a marvel battle I
can't cards that's one more to give new
verses and story events are gonna be
available for Marvel Puzzle Quest as is
Captain Marvel with Talos coming on
March 14th and Captain Marvel has just
joined Marvel contest of Champions with
Nick Fury coming later this month yes I
gotta get my games on thank you guys so
much thank you son uh thank you Judy you
guys please listen to them on the women
of Marvel podcast check out all of their
celebrations over at marvel.com
or subscribe wherever you listen to
podcast thank you guys so much for
having us this was a super fun time
thank you for letting us be on camera
because usually people just listen to
our voices and I love just to talk about
Captain Marvel all the time so I'm here
okay you just find them on the internet
if you want to keep doing that do all
those things I guess and look out for
even more interviews and cool stuff
about Marvel Studios Captain Marvel
coming from Earth's Mightiest show and
of course see Marvel Studios Captain
Marvel in theaters on March 8 yeah come
on and then tell us what you would do if
you had Captain Marvel's superpowers for
a day and you
the hashtag Earth's Mightiest show yes
this is Marvel your
[Music]